joining me now is kevin pafrath he's the
leading in the polls as a top democrat
to replace gavin newsom uh kevin thank
you so much for joining the program i've
been checking you out hearing your
thoughts i'm just curious how you feel
about the democrat establishment
trying to push you out of the way
according to them
this is a republican recall last time i
checked you're a democrat right
that's 100 correct i've been a democrat
since i registered at 18. and look
here's the thing the democratic party
has gone so far to the left i call
myself a jfk style democrat because i
think we got to go back to the common
sense solutions gavin newsom's running a
fear-mongering campaign and that's
because he can't stand on policy
his shiny object to complain about is
larry elder and he can't stand on
anything that matters which is
homelessness housing schooling water
fires the big issues we have because
he's been a failure that's why i'm
running
yeah so talk about your democrat
establishment though why are they
getting involved in this race because
that's anti-democrat right
of course yeah they and they have to
because they're fearful of the people in
charge like gavin newsom they are so
fearful that i can't even get a
democratic attorney to represent me when
i need legal help because they say sorry
if we go on record as supporting a
republican recall then then we can't get
future democratic clients i'm like what
are you talking about it's a california
recall the establishment is so powerful
the money and media has just corrupted
the process and and i don't want to be
tin foil hat but my eyes have just been
opened but i'm going to keep fighting so
kevin i i got to ask you this
why not switch parties or become an
independent business clear that your
party leaders don't want you there
that's okay i believe that voters
determine elections and i have some
progressive priorities that i very much
stand for for example i think we should
pay adults in poverty two thousand
dollars a month to go to future schools
to get a financial education learn a
career so we can get them off of welfare
and off of medical and we can break the
cycle of crime and poverty in the state
and homelessness those are some of the
priorities that i think lean slightly
more left but look i call myself jfk
style because i believe i'm 51.49 i'm so
in the middle okay i just want
californian solutions you don't sound
much like a democrat you sound like a
average day republican moderate um i've
read your your stance on crime and you
don't believe in defunding the police
and all that uh i'm gonna be following
this race brother and even if you don't
win it uh i look forward to seeing you
more thanks so much for coming on the
show
thanks for having me full plan meet
kevin.com